[Music]
This is the short staff from Fiori.
There's only four plays. The first two
are shown from the static posture, so
you have to kind of infer how you might
get into them. So, they're kind of short
and sweet.
possible entrance into first play. I'm
going to use uh iron gate, middle iron
gate double and cross. Now, if he comes
forward to try and grab my arms, I can
knock this down, flick this out, strike,
and then get into
this hole.
Okay, so this is the second play of the
sport shown static
where
here now the possible way to start iron
gate double cross these strikes here
block shift in
here. Take it
[Music]
down. Okay. So, this is the short staff
uh third play. So, it's from a sitting
position. He uh attack me the
rondelle block here. Now, I can go into
anything from the eighth dagger master.
It says I think it says six from the
uh the actual text. And the obvious
thing to do from here would just be drop
this and strip this as I stand
up. This is the fourth and final play of
the small staff. So I sat here in the
lace grass for some reason mind business
and he attacked
me on bell from here and then come
up strip this
out. Okay. Okay, so that's the short
staff. Uh, short and sweet, only four.
And there's a little crossover with the
dagger, which makes it a nice
introduction to the dagger technique.